ähm, Vorschau mäßig.
Dauer kurz bis das Ding gestartet ist,
ist nicht der schnellste.
Wisst ihr worauf ich mich heute richtig freue?
Ich kann heute mein RGB-Feuerwerk
ausprobieren.
Und wie das wieder so ausschaut.
Gut, wie es ausschaut weiß ich, aber
äh, soll ich sagen mal ein RGB-Feuerwerk
anmachen. Und falls jemand auf der Straße
sieht, denkt er sich, alter hat er Max
ein geiles RGB-Feuerwerk.
Oder auch nicht, wahrscheinlich geht heute eh keiner
raus.
Alter, was geht mit der Musik ab?
What the fuck?
So, äh, wie gesagt Leute,
jetzt muss ich mein Streaming-PC noch kurz anmachen.
Dass ich was sehe.
So, Tastatur wieder umstecken.
Blub blub, blub blub blub.
Ah, yes, exellent.
Ok, wunderbar.
Ich hab da noch Skype drauf installiert.
Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Jedes Mal was ich mache, nachdem ich den Rechner
neu gestartet hab, ist einfach Skype ausschalten.
Skype ist auch so most, most
useless Programm ever, jetzt
mittlerweile. Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
als ich angefangen hab mit YouTube, war Skype
so der Shit.
Alle, alle haben so die Sachen über Skype gemacht.
Ich war glaube ich jetzt 3 Jahre oder so
oder 4 Jahre nicht mehr in Skype eingeloggt.
So.
So, also Streaming-PC läuft.
Exellent.
E-Modes auf sinnvolle Größe
schrumpfen.
Auf geht's würde ich sagen.
Hat, hat Twitch kapiert,
dass wir 1080p haben?
Please Twitch,
1080p Leute, ist 1080p?
Haha, exquisite.
Nice, so muss das sein.
1080p, ja, weil manchmal spackt das rum.
Also nicht wundern, wir haben
15 Sekunden Delay.
Old Battlefield 3, ja wir machen jetzt
bis, bis maximal
Leute, maximal 20.30 Uhr.
Also bis, bis, also maximal so
sagen wir mal 3,
3,5 Stunden, wenn's hochkommt.
Oh, das ist Dirty-Wee, Dirty-Wee Shop Musik.
Beste.
Und wie sieht's bei euch heute aus?
Hat irgendjemand
sich um 5 Ecken doch Feuerwerk geholt
oder, oder lasst es bleiben?
Ihr könnt joinen, wie ihr lustig seid.
Ja.
Guck erst mal, ob bei Venice Unleashed irgendwas kommt.
Was gibt's?
Also ich hab nix.
Aber ich mach ja schon seit Jahren kein großartiges Feuerwerk mehr.
Mister Army, du kannst
gerne mich ne Runde carryen.
Verkuck mal, ob's überhaupt nen gescheiten Server gibt.
Aber was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
SPS Infantry, No Air Vehicle.
Das könnte eigentlich was für...
Mitro, Conquest Metro, ach du Scheiße.
Was soll das wirklich geben?
Gun Master Siebertower.
Das könnte man sich auch nochmal ne Runde geben.
Play Perium Silvester Party.
Alles klar.
Da können wir nicht joinen.
Wisst ihr was, wir spielen jetzt mal
wir spielen jetzt mal
ne Runde Metro einfach, weil's
bisschen aufwärmt.
Oh, was lad ich mir da für Mods runter?
Die Pings stimmen nicht, die da drin stehen.
Warte mal ab, wenn die auf dem Server sind,
siehst du wieder viel besser aus.
Die Pings sind fail.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum die pingen,
wenn das überhaupt nicht stimmt.
Och guck mal, mit weapon...
Exquisite Mapfold.
Seht ihr das hier?
Können wir Grand Bazaar voten.
Best of all, das sieht da schon mal
richtig bigbrainig aus hier.
Moment, was? Level 2?
Man kann Level 2 sein?
Wirklich?
Normalerweise...
Hä? Normalerweise ist man doch hier immer Level 1?
Warum sind die Level 2?
Ah, ich hab wirklich Dranada Ping.
Fuck.
Okay, mit Dranada Ping kann man das Game nicht spielen.
Vergiss es. Ist das ein Asia Server?
Okay, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob die...
Dranada Ping, sag mal.
Okay.
Ja, ich hab so die Vermutung, das ist keine
allzu gute Idee gewesen.
Komm, wir awnen.
Die AliExpress-Chinesen
werden jetzt owned.
Also kann das sein, dass die Namensplatten
der Spiele zu spät eingeblendet werden
oder irgendwie sowas? Ganz, ganz
merkwürdig.
Exquisite.
Ach, du große...
Okay.
Alter, wie kann ich... Warum kann ich überhaupt
Leute killen mit einem Dranada Ping?
Ist doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht möglich.
Ich mein... Alter.
300er Ping.
Wollt ihr mich rollen?
So, holen wir die G18 raus,
wenn's gebashed...
Okay, nein, vergiss es.
Du kannst Dranada Ping
nicht spielen. Das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, T-Harmine ist es.
Gibt keine gescheiten Server gerade, wie es aussieht.
Operation Metro... Ah, Moment, da war ich doch
grad drauf.
DC. Alter, ich will disconnecten.
DC.
Game.
Ich darf nicht. Ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt.
Aber diese Map-Vote-Features sind richtig nice.
Eigentlich mal ein grafischer Map-Vote.
So, was haben wir...
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Rush
Demavent Peak.
64 Mann, das ist
echt ziemlich
heftiger Pains-Champ.
Okay, wir probieren das mal aus.
Ansonsten gehen wir...
Wir gucken eben mal, was
official angesagt ist.
Hier gab's doch eben noch einen 24-Spieler-Server.
Wo ist der hin?
Ich hab's genau gesehen,
vor 5 Minuten,
bevor ich den Stream angemacht hab,
ohne Scheiß, gab's hier noch
einen 24-Spieler-Server.
Ja.
Oh, es sieht so aus, als ist
Spawn-Rape angesagt.
Das fängt ja schon...
Das fängt ja schon mal exzellent an.
Guck mal, der rett's keiner!
Der rett's keiner! Der rett's...
Der rett's Schneiber-Dudes hier!
Okay, ne, das kannst du ja nicht spielen.
Wobei, wisst ihr was, wir brauchen einfach
gute Leute, da werden die jetzt gefickt.
Easy. 9er Ping, Leute!
Poggers! 9er Ping!
Macht es erstmal nach.
Das ist ja wie, als würde es bei mir
im Keller stehen.
Da kannst du nicht runter.
Okay.
Von da
muss cheaten.
Instant-Cheat, easy.
Doch.
Das ist Venice.
Das ist...
Der Martin-Router ist am Start.
Jawoll.
Der Martin-Router?
Ne, das kannst du vergessen hier gerade.
Thomas Black Ops Call for...
Ey, ich hab letztens
ne Runde Zombies gespielt.
Das macht tatsächlich Bock.
Aber ich hab
echt absolut keinen Bock
auf Skill-Base-Matchmaking-Multiplayer.
Null.
Alter, was ist... Wie scharf sind die denn hier?
Hier stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Das ist doch definitiv
grad nicht normal, oder?
What the hell?
Okay, es ist 64 Mann.
Das darf man nicht vergessen, aber trotzdem.
Skill-Base-Matchmaking so
Müll, ja.
Aber richtig.
Aber 64...
Die hauen ja eh schon übelst rein,
wie man es hier grad sieht.
Sonst werden wir nicht fast mit Tickets dauern.
Jetzt gehen wir hier grad ab.
Easy Win, Leute.
Kaum sind wir drin.
Was? Der ist nicht tot.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Der ist nicht tot.
Was ist das?
Okay, der hat zwar einen niedrigen Ping, aber hat das Ding irgendwie drei Spiele.
Der hat einfach Packet-Loss, oder was?
Der Dude ist nicht tot.
Ich fass es dann.
Hallo?
Oh, hier kommen jetzt gleich welche.
Achtung.
Irgendwas snipet hier auf mich.
Ich hab noch nicht mal eine Ahnung, was hier überhaupt snipet.
Das ist zu viel. Alter, das sind zu viele Leute.
Das sind definitiv zu viele Leute.
Stirbt nix?
Die Maps aus Cold War kommen aus der Hölle, ist das so?
Wahrscheinlich spielen die eh wieder
24-7 Nuke-Tower.
Oh, warte mal, wir haben Doppelsquad-Cover.
Warum haben wir denn sowas? Wir brauchen Ammo.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ich keine 64-Spieler-Rush-Surfer mag, normalerweise.
Warte mal, ist da... stellt es dir hinten noch irgendeinen Dude?
Ich check's nicht.
Ich steige da mal durch.
Ich steige... also 64-Spiel ist zu krass.
Da blickst du nicht durch.
Aber wenn gute Mitspieler haben,
dann können wir die Massive-Fashion...
Wo ist der hin?
Der hat grad...
Der Dude hat grad legit einfach in die Luft aufgelöst.
So, jetzt machen wir uns...
Flankerino.
Was ist denn hier schon wieder?
Hallo? Nein! Game, please!
Shit Grenade!
Monka.
Monka Hyper X.
Ah.
Ich kann nicht retzen.
Ich kann nicht retzen. Hier ist... hier ist...
What the hell?
64-Spieler, ey!
Nein, ich schwach.
What the hell?
64-Spieler, ey!
Nein, ich vote-banne nicht random irgendwelche Leute.
64... das sind die Typen im Heli.
64-Spieler.
Das ist so abgedrehter Shit, ey.
Lass mich hoch.
Weil...
Maxi, empfiehst du 2 oder 3 Monitore?
Schau drauf an, was du machen willst.
Was hast du denn so vor?
Was ist so Anwendungszweck?
Jetzt machen die hier Reverse-Boost-Dinge oder was?
What? What?
What?
Der cheatet die Gegner, oder?
Irgendwas stimmt doch hier nicht.
Also hier ist definitiv
irgendwas faul.
Ach, du große Scheiße.
Nein, nein, ich bleib hinterm Felsen.
Oh, fuck.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Leute, denn mal wenn Peak Rushed,
das ist eine gute Sache, dass mehr nicht immer besser ist.
Da bringt noch nicht mal
Smoke-Action was.
Game, du darfst mich hier ruhig rauf lassen übrigens.
Game, lass mich...
Game, lass mich doch mal rauf.
Geht doch.
Irgendwas stimmt hier auch definitiv nicht.
Guck mal, jetzt stehen sie schon da drüben.
Und sterben... Ey, sag mal.
Wie wärs...
Wie wärs mit sterben?
Nee, also...
64 Mann der immer wenn Peak Rushed ist nur wirklich
Massive Suck.
Da machst du auch nix.
Der Herr Ruter ist am Start, guckt euch an.
Der hat die Sonnenbrille falsch rum.
Gibt Style-Points.
Also wir machen das jetzt nochmal, die Runde.
Und gucken da mal, was nächste Runde
geladen wird. Und wenn das weiterhin so...
...so merkwürdig bleibt...
...dann...
...durchladen.
Im Zweifelsfall auch einfach
auffischen.
What the fuck?
Also irgendwas stimmt mit dem Gegner
nicht, ohne Scheiß.
Irgendwas ist da ganz merkwürdig.
Ja, das jetzt wird rechts
rumgestellt.
Das ist ja fast wie Skill-Based-Matchmaking,
glaube ich. Was ist denn hier los?
Lass uns einfach
Rite-Time-Gun-Master füllen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das können wir tatsächlich machen.
Aber du kannst ruhig... Also wenn du willst, kannst
ja mal reinjoin.
Wir versuchen die wenigstens mal
zu bashen, nächste Runde.
Oh fuck, hier ist mir noch nicht mal safe.
Okay, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Mit der auglen Header
über die Distanz von der Map.
Also...
...von da!
Von da!
Was ist denn hier... Was ist das denn?
Was ist das denn?
Ach ja Leute, übrigens
für alle, die jetzt gerade neu dazugekommen sind
und gestern nicht da waren.
Wir haben jetzt Emotes.
Tribut und 14 Monate, Dankeschön.
Das ist der Army.
Das ist der Army. Gibt es da irgendwo einen gescheiten Server?
Der Anderen?
Irgendwas, was noch da ist,
weil das kannst du nicht spielen.
Das ist ja nicht spielbar gerade.
Ich mache mal kurz die Kirby-Musik aus.
Die ist gerade ein bisschen...
Ah nee, die Nintendo-Musik ist gerade ein bisschen hartnäckig.
Vielleicht irgendein anderes Squad,
wo Leute vorne rumstelzen oder so?
Nicht wirklich.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Auf dem Asias-Server waren die Leute 102.
Na ja, Rush gibt es ja nicht.
Rush ist das der einzige Server.
Wir gehen danach wirklich Gun Master rein.
Oder sowas in der Richtung halt.
Nee, das ist doch der Witz.
Du kannst mal gucken, ob du danach reinkommst.
Eine Runde spiele ich noch.
Also ich will jetzt mal gucken, wer von Anfang an dabei ist.
Aber das ist wirklich gerade absolut witzlos.
METO!
Fuck, Alter!
Als wäre das doch nicht schlimm gewesen.
Jetzt kommt 64 mal ein Metro.
Gut, zum Glück waren wir in den letzten 5 Minuten drin.
Der Router, der war richtig gut.
Der hat geroutet.
Schon eine Fritzbox.
Alter, war das schlecht.
Boating map has started.
Ja, alles klar.
Sand Crossing, wunderbar.
Ist das die Vaio Experience?
Ja.
Ist so.
Off-Game.
So, komm mal gucken.
Probier ich jetzt noch mal gucken, was wir sind.
Attack, Defense, sonst wie.
Also auf Normal Attack, weggespornwrapped werden, hab ich keinen Bock.
Moin, Spiegel.
Sonst den Chat gucken, hab ich irgendwas übersehen.
Ja, wie gesagt,
mit den Monitoren, ich hab aktuell zwei.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich auch zwei.
Einen kleinen Notebook-Monitor und einen
Curved, frag mich nicht.
75.000 Zoll.
1000 Zoll, Defense.
Ah, guck mal, die Curved hat's
auch schon am Start.
Oh ne,
da wird schon losgesniped aus dem Spawn,
Alter.
Aber eins muss man echt mal sagen,
Netro sieht wirklich cool aus, ne?
Ohne Plaufilter.
Wie, der ist nicht tot? Ernsthaft nicht?
Wirklich?
Das ist definitiv nicht normal hier gerade, was da abgeht.
Also, das kann sie mir net erzählen.
Die können mir net erzählen,
dass der mich aus dem Spawn
durch den Ritz
von diesem komischen
Betonding gesniped hat.
Also, dann gehen wir jetzt auf den
Gunmaster-Server, wo...
wo muss man hin?
Wart mal, wo ist denn der
Gunmaster-Server?
Tdm
Close Quarter?
Ne, das war der Asia-Server mit Rana
oder Ping.
Also, gehen wir mal hier,
Tags, Gunfight.
Ne, nicht Gunfight.
Gun...
...Gunmaster.
Aber das kann ich auch net lang spielen.
Sieber Tower? Ne, ist das Hardcore?
Ach, Gunmaster und Knight.
Oh, jetzt wird's aber advanced hier.
Den da?
Oh, was wir da für ein Ping haben.
Ich hab ja nur eins auf.
Operation 925.
An die Map kann ich mich überhaupt
nicht mehr erinnern. War das die...
War das die Map, die in diesem... Ne.
Was ist das für eine Map?
Ehrlich net?
Guck mal, aber Map... Map-Vote
ist noch mal ziemlich cool.
Was ist das für eine Map?
Welche war denn das noch mal?
Guck mal, da fährt ein Auto.
Also, Leute, wenn ihr mitspielen wollt...
Go, go, go.
Das war ein Gemässer.
Der messert mich jetzt von der Seite.
Ich sag... Ne, doch nicht.
Aber Nighttime sieht die cool aus.
Das hat irgendwie was.
Guck mal, wisst ihr, was ich cool finde?
Dass sogar in Battlefield 3
das mit den Lichtquellen gut funktioniert.
Office Map. Also, wer will?
Das ist eine DLC-Map.
Das ist eine Close Quarters-Map, ja.
Fällt euch mal auf, wie gut der Sound
von Battlefield 3 ist.
Oh, scheiße, der Sound
von dem Game ist Poggers.
K.P. Digger.
Genau.
Auf geht's.
Auf der Toilette
hat es Non-RTX-Spiegel.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wo ist das Klo?
Moment, ich muss das Klo suchen.
Leute, ich muss das Klo suchen.
Leute, wo ist das?
Hier ist das Klo. Nee, das ist der Fahrstuhl.
Kann man Fahrstuhl fahren?
Wo ist das Klo?
Und KS.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen den Server.
Ah, doch, jetzt.
Jetzt kommen die Leute.
Wo ist das Klo? Ich finde das Klo nicht.
Oh, oh, das sieht nicht gut aus.
Äh.
Okay, es sind nicht alle
Spiegelungen gut.
Das sieht aus wie
irgendein 2D-Game
von 1995.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal an.
Weil, was willst du machen, ne?
Mr. Ami ist... Ach, guck mal, hier unten ist vielleicht das Klo.
Klo? Hallo? Klo?
Kein Klo.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal an.
Weil, was willst du machen, ne?
Mr. Ami ist... Ach, guck mal, hier unten ist vielleicht das Klo.
Klo? Hallo? Klo?
Ich glaube, wir kriegen den Server nicht voll.
Der Name des Servers ist genau BHG.
Ihr müsst einfach Tax-Filtern,
Night-Time
und Gun-Game.
Und dann ist easy win.
Komm in die Mitte, Max, zeig dir das Klo.
Exzellent. Ich eile.
Max, zeig dir das Klo. Exzellent. Ich eile.
Ich kriege jetzt das Klo gezeigt.
Ich bin ziemlich in der Mitte. Da, da ist er. Stopp, stehenbleiben.
Ist das der Mr. Avi? Nee. Schräg. Egal, ich glaube wir sollten anfangen.
Lass anfangen. Das ist nicht die Mitte. Ich kenne mich auf der Map nicht aus. Ist hier die Mitte?
Ist das die Mitte? Ach guck mal, hier ist das Klo. Das ist wirklich kein RTX-Spiegel. Echt nicht.
Also, als erstes ist das gar kein Spiegel mehr und die übrigbleibenden Sachen sind definitiv nicht RTX-On.
Aber wisst ihr wie cool das ist, wie die das gemacht haben, was hier alles kaputt geht auf der Map?
Es riecht Spock aus. Oh. Ich habe das Klo gefunden.
Der fasst wie in der Matrix an. So. Leute, auf gehts. Fangen wir an.
Schreckt. Der Server ist gleich voll. Können wir loslegen. Du wolltest das Scheißhaus sehen.
Du hast es doch gesehen. Ich war doch gerade da.
Pass auf, pass auf. Wir warten jetzt bis einer reinkommt, dann messern wir ihn.
Psst, psst, psst. Okay. Da kommt keiner rein. Ich wollte ein Big Brain Messer machen.
Boah, sind zu viele. Massive Tauchstation. Oh.
3 bis 22. Nee. Wie gesagt, maximal 30 oder bis ich keinen Bock mehr habe.
Ich dachte da ist einer. Maximal bis ich keinen Bock mehr habe. Spätestens maximal 30 oder bis ich keinen Bock mehr habe.
Alter, die Maps. Jetzt weiß ich auch wieder. Die Close Quarter Maps haben mich immer voll verrückt gemacht.
Weil du denkst immer, dass Gegner um dich drum herum sind. Immer. Du hörst 50 Milliarden Schritte von allen Seiten.
Hörst du die über mir? Das macht dich verrückt. Monka X. Monka Hyper. Die Schritte machen dich verrückt in dem Game.
Aber Nightmap finde ich echt immer noch sehr nice. Hyper nice. Und wie gut das mit den Lichtquellen aussieht.
Echt, Porgers ist das. Wo ist denn hier was? Alter, was ist hier los? Die werden voll zerstört. Warum werden die so zerstört?
Alter, was ist hier los? Die werden voll zerstört. Warum werden die so zerstört? Was ist das für ein Massaker an der Treppe?
Und ich habe keine An-O-M-G-Schnur-Sitze. Es ist fucking friendly fire an. Ach du Scheiße. Das ist der Hardcore-Server hier.
Das hätte DICE mit wenig Aufwand machen können. Korrekt.
Alter, hier checkst du ja nichts. Das ist so pepega. Das ist so pepega. Die sind für die FP90.
Ich bin heute so für Pepega-Waffe. Wow. Huge Pepega-Waffe. Einfach mal reingesprayt.
Ein bisschen schnelleres Life-Rack wäre halt auch sinnvoll auf den Maps. Hoffentlich hat Battlefield 6 dynamisches Wetter und Tageszeiten.
Ich sag euch ganz ehrlich, bevor ich an sowas denke, denke ich mir halt, Battlefield könnte einfach gescheites Gameplay machen. Das wäre äußerst nice.
Hier ist nichts. Alter, ich kenne die Map-Lad. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo hier was ist. Kommt man hier durch vielleicht?
Hä? Von der Vorderseite weggerotzt mit der Magnum. Was ich mir wünschen würde für Battlefield 6, es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Sachen.
Die sollen sich auf das Gameplay konzentrieren und nicht auf 50 Unlockables und Geschiss und sonst was und ich will Rush auf guten Maps. Fertig. Reicht mir.
Ich meine, im Prinzip habe ich damit gesagt, ich will ein geiles Game, aber ja. Richtig ins Gesicht geballert.
Ja super, Schatz, zu wenig Leben. Mit der P9 einfach reingesprayt. Die Nachtmaps sind schon cool. Das hat irgendwie was. Also ich mach das.
Ich glaube, es reicht, wenn ich hier rumstelse. War das die Map, wo man durch die Wände ballern konnte? Oh hier ist das Klo. Ich habe das Klo gefunden Leute.
Massive Toilettenställs. Huge Toilettenställs. Da war noch einer in der Ecke. Wow. Alter, was ist das für eine Waffe? Fuck, wie die verzieht.
What the fuck? Die kannst du hier überhaupt nicht kontrollieren, wenn du da Dauerfeuer machst.
Meine Güte. Richt pepega Dauerfeuer. Was, Server ruckelt? Ernsthaft? Stimmt, stimmt. Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, Server ruckelt. Jetzt wo er es sagt.
What the fuck? Hier war doch einer. Da stellt mich jetzt einer von uns. Passt auf, pass auf. Ich wollte eigentlich sagen, wir warten jetzt hier bis einer kommt und Messern dehnt.
Aber wir müssen ja noch genug Messer Kills machen. Was ist denn unter mir los da gerade?
Da unten. Treppenställs. Treppenställs.
Pass auf, die spawnen jetzt woanders. Wow. Fuck. Ja, richtig. Du hast hier permanent Paranoia, ohne Scheiß.
Deswegen mochte ich diese Sorte von Close Quarters Maps nicht. Du hast permanent gedacht, so ein bisschen wie in Modern Warfare, du hast Gegner über deinem Kopf oder vor dir oder links oder so.
Hört ihr das? Das hört sich original an. Wo geht es hier überhaupt lang?
Ich würde gerne retzen, by the way. Da ist was. Die werden jetzt erstellt.
Der Server laggt. Der laggt, ohne Scheiß. Guys, habt ihr das gesehen? Das ganze Magazin an LMG Rounds.
Das ist richtig Paranoia, mach ich das. Das laggt. Fuck.
Pass auf.
Einfach Head Clitchen. Wisst ihr was das Geil ist? Head Clitchen geht in jedem Game. Einfach easy Head Clitch. Easy ist Head Clitch of my life hier.
Head Clitchen, wenn ihr euch fragt, was sollt ihr in einem Shooter machen, es gibt zwei Antworten. Head Clitchen und Treppenaufgang Campen.
Das sind einfach die zwei Sachen, die immer gehen.
Da war was, oder? Jetzt bin ich direkt vor dem und runter gesprungen.
Da hört man auch, dass es an den Waffen laggt. Ihr habt es eben beim Dauerfeuer gemerkt. Es hat einfach Schüsse ausge... Alter.
Ich kann immer vorwärts laufen.
Okay, das laggt hardcore. Das ist schon... Nicht mal Poggers.
Absolut nicht mal Poggers. Alter.
Bewege dich, Mann. Krasser Elite-Soldat bleibt an der Treppe hängen.
Fuck.
Ich bräuchte jetzt mal einen Heal, aber Heal gibt es nicht, oder? Da kann es nicht rauspieken.
Ach, das ist jetzt auch noch DMR.
Größte PP-Gawaffe im ganzen Game.
Manchmal bleibt man stehen, obwohl man drückt. Ja, ist echt so.
Fuck. Wir hätten gewinnen können.
Aber das ist Kacke, wenn das laggt.
Jetzt müssen wir mal was ausprobieren.
Kann man? Kann man, wenn es anliegt, doppelt starten?
Ich kann eingeloggt bleiben?
Hätte ja funktionieren können, aber hätte ich nämlich gleich noch am neuen Server gucken können.
Also auf dem Server kann ich nicht weiterspielen, das laggt.
Wir können auch mal gucken, was es für offizielle Server gibt.
Was haben wir denn am Start?
Tolle Alternativen gibt es ja da nicht.
Was gibt es denn hier?
Da spielen aber die ganzen guten Leute, da kann man nicht so viel Bam über Bam machen.
Oh, Siebertower.
Das ist die Paranoia-Map-Extreme.
Ist connected, oder? Oh, nee, nee.
Brauchen wir es.
Siebertower bei Nacht. Okay, das ist auch cool.
Hatte ich noch nicht.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt weniger laggt.
Ja, nee, nee, nee, es laggt immer noch.
Es laggt immer noch.
Nee, muss anderen Server.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Es laggt immer noch.
Kacke.
Was gibt es denn? Gibt es da noch irgendwas?
Okay.
Das wäre nämlich richtig Poggers gewesen.
Okay, also was sind eigentlich die Server mit Leuten?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Damavent Peak, 64 Spieler, war ja schon klasse, da fuck, wie ist denn das?
Golfo Forman, 76. Wobei, ist Golfo Forman nicht relativ groß?
Zeig noch mal her.
Mal gucken, wie der Ping ist.
Wahrscheinlich auch wieder 800er Ping oder irgendwas.
Ich glaube, wir müssen auf die offiziellen Server ausfallen.
Haben wir?
Also sogar das Scoreboard 26, das geht doch.
Okay, wir brauchen mal ein gutes Squad.
Ich weiß nicht, Mr. Army, ob du auch drauf willst.
War nice, wenn wir gescheite Leute hätten.
Conquest skaliert besser mit vielen Spielern, das ist richtig, ja.
Ich habe den Eindruck, wir kriegen ein bisschen auf den Sack.
Also, falls du rein willst, ich gehe mal aus dem Squad und ich mache...
Moment.
Man konnte gar kein neues Squad aufmachen.
Na gut, ich gehe mal bei Golf rein.
Server ist voll.
Da lief ein Laufenwörter.
Ich bin EU-Seite, aber wenn du drin bist, kann ich auch versuchen, es zu wechseln.
Erst, wievieler brauchen der, um seinen komischen Defi rauszuholen?
Alter, ja, ja, lass mich nur...
Auf dem Dach?
What?
Ich bin da hoch, habt ihr mir der G18 in den Kopf geschossen?
Oder habt mich One-Shotted?
Wollt ihr mich rollen, Leute?
Ich würde hier am liebsten Rush spielen.
Ich glaube, ich gehe dann, wenn das ausgelutscht ist, hier gehe ich auf den offiziellen Rush-Server und spiele noch ein paar Runden.
Auf den meisten Servern kann man nicht mehr switchen, was ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich doof finde.
Weil die haben ja auch kein Freundesystem.
Und ohne Freundesystem ist halt Massive Suck.
Ich weiß nicht, von wo was schießt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall scharf auf uns.
Stelzen wir uns mal hier.
Habt ihr das auch gehört?
Respawn Stelzen ist hier irgendwo.
Mein Problem ist, ich kenne die Map nicht mehr, ich weiß nicht, wo es hoch geht.
Wo ging es denn hier noch mal rauf?
Wo geht es denn hier rauf?
Lul, weh.
Gar nicht? Auf der anderen Seite?
Scheint gar nicht, aber hier.
Hier.
Ich meine, ich muss schon sagen, äußerst detailliert.
Kann man sagen, da ging es gar nicht rauf.
Man musste das machen, man musste mit dem Fallschirm springen.
Ohje, da habe ich ja Bock drauf.
Stimmt, das ist die Map mit den Kran-Campern.
Oh Gott, das wird das wieder. Guckt mal hier.
11 hat das... Ich will doch einfach nur irgendwie...
Baschen, Alter.
Ah, okay.
BP guy aimed.
Ich will doch einfach nur baschen, Alter, baschen.
Ah, da ist er. Nice, ein Cue-System, ja.
Vor allem...
Vor allem, was sie auf jeden Fall brauchen,
ist irgendwas ein bisschen ausgefallen.
Sag mal, was ist denn bei den Gegnern los?
Rooftop-Schneivers, ja.
Oh Mann.
Leute, ich sehe schon kommen, heute gibt es keine Gescheiterunden.
Gibt es hier irgendein Auto, wo wir hier wegkommen?
Ich renne doch da jetzt hin, das dauert 5 Stunden.
Die Besten erstmal kicken, ja, das ist Low-Brain.
Das ist richtig Low-Brain-Aktion.
Ey, das ist ja Schneiber-Dudes über die ganze Map verteilt.
Pass auf, gleich kriegen wir den Kopf geschnallbt.
Von irgendwo von da oben. Guckt mal hier, guckt euch an.
Der sitzt das ganze Game da. Macht sonst nix.
Okay, okay, was können wir wollen?
Riverside, Caspian Border, Asadi Pallet, Banadessa.
Alles kacke.
Grand Bazaar, Alter, 64 Mann, in your face.
Ich hab übrigens einen Heli-Stelzer gehört über mich.
Ey, das ist doch witzlos.
Echter Witz.
Aber warum kicken sie eigentlich die Leute?
Hoffentlich ist das bald vorbei und dann gibt es ordentliche Map.
Dann hätte ich es rumgehockelt.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt ist er am Start.
Oh, oh, oh.
Also Spaß ist was anderes, Leute.
Residenz Leaper, aber richtig Residenz Leaper, ey.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir lassen uns jetzt einfach bashen.
Bashen, 5, 3 Stickets, 3 Stickets.
Ist gleich vorbei.
Jawoll, bash mich, easy.
Erstmal eine Runde T-Baggen, jawoll.
23, gleich ist es vorbei, gleich ist es vorbei.
Gleich ist es vorbei.
Just don't play anymore.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Was Operation Riverside?
Gib mir Grand Bazaar oder irgendwas Gescheites.
Was war denn Operation, Moment.
Operation Riverside, war das die Herbstmap?
War das diese herbstliche Map?
Riverside?
Mal gucken, wenn nicht wird geleafed.
Ist gerade wirklich anstrengend.
Wo haben wir denn offizielle Server am Start?
No Rules.
24 Mann Demavent Peak.
Das könnte man sich danach vielleicht sogar fast mal geben.
Warum, warum, warum, warum voten die eigentlich?
72, na gut 72.0, da hat Heli Stels die ganze Zeit wahrscheinlich.
Ich würde jetzt gerne mal irgendwas spielen, wo ich erstens den Spielmodus halbwegs aufspiele
und eine Map, die ich kenne und irgendwas, wo nicht instant in...
Oh, das ist eine Schneiber Map.
Ob das gäbe ich...
Ey, wenn das, Leute, wenn das keine Schneiber Map ist.
Das ist die Deluxe Schneiber Map.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt mal, wie offen das Ganze ist.
So, wisst ihr was?
Wir fahren jetzt easy.
Wir fahren jetzt easy Motorrad.
Kann man mal Map größer machen.
Moin.
Ich hätte nicht auf den Chat gucken sollen.
Erst mal schön gegen den Felsen.
C.
Jawoll, C.
Wow.
Achtung, Achtung.
Voll krasse Driving Skills.
Okay, ich verpiss mich mal.
Alles abgeliegt.
Nice.
Hab ich gut geswitcht.
Okay, geht nicht, weil Battlefield.
Weil Battlefield Logik.
Was echt?
Es gibt ein Motorradrennen-Mod?
Okay, das ist nice.
Nice, dankesch.
Danke, danke.
Was ist denn das?
Was bin ich jetzt überhaupt?
Ah, Angie, okay.
Wer wird jetzt gewascht, oder?
What?
Ist der auf dem Dach?
Das erinnert mich an das Warzone.
Leute, das erinnert mich mega an das Warzone-Fabrikhaus, oder?
Sagt mal.
He, he, he, he, he.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Hilfe, ich bin Java-Entwickler und komme nicht mehr raus.
Oh je.
Da hilft nur Al-Install.
Ich habe jetzt halt so eine...
Okay.
Pass mal auf, jetzt wallbangen wir den mit der Nate.
Kommt man hier eigentlich raus, irgendwie?
Hey, oder?
Hey, hey.
Oh, Battlefield, come on.
Please.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Na, das hast du dir so gedacht, Alter.
Das hast du dir so gedacht.
Der wollte mich mit seinem Motorrad...
Wahrscheinlich wollte er noch nicht mal absichtlich mit seinem Motorrad Road killen.
Das war nur Zufall.
Okay.
B.
C.
Excellent.
Bleib am App.
Oh Gott.
Alter, wie ich das an Conquest hasse, ey.
Eis.
Oh, da drin ist ordentlich was los.
Da drin ist ordentlich was los.
Oder auf dem Dach.
Ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher.
Entweder auf dem Dach.
Battlefield, was ist mit dir los?
Warum gehen die ganzen Sprungdinger nicht?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, MonkaS.
Explodieren, explodieren.
Schreckt.
Äh.
Little Bird, ich...
Wenn ich...
Weißt du, was passiert, wenn ich den Little Bird nehme?
Wenn ich den Little Bird nehme, dann bin ich erstmal down.
Pass mal auf.
Wir stingern den jetzt.
Alter.
Ich warte, bis der Army gespawnt ist.
Ich hoffe, es kommen noch ein paar Leute ins Squad, weil zu zweit zackt ein bisschen.
Spawn.
Vier, drei, zwei, eins, jetzt.
Geht nicht.
Der, der aimt mich ab.
Der Typ aimt mich einfach ab.
Ah.
Nein, ich habe nicht mal eine Granate, nicht mal einen Raketenwerfer dabei.
Okay, wir müssen dringend...
Assault.
Ah, nice.
Poggers.
Komm, jetzt haben wir eine M16 gepick-up, dann können wir auch die M16 verwenden.
Ja.
Da sind noch mehr, da sind noch mehr.
Wie, das hat er überlebt?
Kommt her.
Oh, da unten kommt was.
Da kommt gleich was.
Hä?
Die Dudes kommen gleich hier, ich dachte euch, ich dachte euch, ich wusste, ich wusste,
wie der ist tot.
He, he.
Lul, Kacknoop.
Oh.
Omega-Lul.
Alter, huge schreckt.
M16.
Ist schon ein OP-Kackding, ne?
Okay, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Äh, ich speichere mir das...
Oh, fuck.
Ah, Sekunde.
Öh, Öh, Öh, Overlay, Overlay, Overlay.
Ha, Overlay.
UPS, Status.
Wir speichern das einfach mal, weil's geht.
Mr.
Army, ich eile.
What, what, what, what is happening?
Sag mal, ich hör echt da auf dem Dach welche lau...
Meine wei, Leute, warum vote-banen die hier wie verrückt rum?
Oh, jetzt kommen sie von vorne, fuck, ich muss wieder zurück.
Äh, wisst ihr, Army, ich glaub, ich komm da, ich versuch's mal.
Bist du außen oder drinnen?
Fuck.
Jetzt war keine gute Idee, du kannst reinspornen.
Ist das Smoke, was...
Was hab ich denn da dabei, nix.
Oh, Panzer, Pantsman rückt an.
Der Pantsman rückt an, nein.
Ich hätte unten lang laufen müssen, ich bin doch doof, ich komm doch um die Ecke.
Ja, vote-kick anzeigen, wer gewartet hat, ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache.
Nicht sterben, nicht sterben.
Ich spawn mal als...
Ich mein, hier ist zwar der Pantsman am Start, aber ich spawn mal als Sturmsoldat rein mit
Medikit und Defi und nicht diesen komischen Crap, den ich da gerade aufgepickt hab.
Ich hab gehört, wir stürmen jetzt in die Gegner rein.
Ja, alles klar, voll verschissen, voll verschissen, Leute, aber richtig krass verkackt.
Pepega-Aim, Leute, wir haben das passende Emote dafür, lasst mal Pepega-Aim sehen jetzt.
Ist schon alles tot?
Alles weg?
Geil, top.
Top, erst mal gespart und ins in die Luft geflogen.
Ich würd sagen, wir spawnen C, wir spawnen C rein.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Oh, da hat was auf mich geaimt.
Könnt ihr mal aufhören auch noch zu treffen, Gegner?
Der Typ die ganze Runde im Heli.
Ja, das ist aber so.
Also generell in Conquest die meisten Kills sind die Heli und Jett-Typen, aber eher die
Heli-Typen, eher die Heli-Typen.
Krieg ich doch noch nen Rats, auf jeden Fall.
Rush ist der beste, ja, geb ich dir recht.
Rush ist der beste Spielmodus, da gibt's nix.
Rush beste.
Conquest ist auch mal ganz entspannend zwischendurch.
Conquest Finish ist eigentlich nur richtig im Squad richtig nice.
Pass mal auf, easy kill, easy kill.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Gleich ins in den Pilot rausgeschossen.
Face Bewerbung ist raus.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh Leute, ich seh da was über mir, was mir gar nicht gefällt.
Das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht da über mir.
AC-130 am Start.
Oh, oh, da stehen sie.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Oh shit, shit, shit, ich muss weg.
Leute, ich muss weg.
Fuck.
Nein.
Monka.
Alles weggepascht.
Die kommen hier aber nicht mehr raus.
Achtung, Massive-Nade.
Ich guck, dass von hinten nichts kommt.
Gucken wir die Seite.
Alter, sag mal, kann ich mal an was Normalem sterben?
Ich kann nur spawnen.
Was, ernsthaft?
Man kann doch AC-130 schießen in dem Game.
Oh, oh, da ist ein Panzer, da ist ein Panzer.
Der Panzmann.
Der Panzmann himself steht auf dem Basch.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung jetzt.
Voller Pulle.
Jawoll, gib alles, gib alles, gib alles.
Ich weiß nicht von wo, aber rein, rein, rein hier.
Alter, Battlefield, komm on, lass mich hüpfen.
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt rein.
Was?
Das ist anstrengend, das ist echt anstrengend, Leute.
Oh, da kommt ein Panzer, da kommt ein Panzer an.
Mein Problem ist, ich kenne die Winkel überhaupt nicht richtig auf der Map.
Oh, aber das kann, ich glaube da kann der Panzer nicht reinballern.
Alter, ich bin paranoid hier, überall ist was.
Shit, Alter.
Und hier sind noch 50 Milliarden Gegner drin.
Oh, oh.
Richtig schwitzen, das ist härter als Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Übrigens, die Granate hat hinter der Kiste auf mir, 5, 4, 3, 2.
Brain-Lag, Leute, Brain-Lag, Massive-Brain-Lag.
Oder Game-Lag, eins von beiden.
Fahren jetzt einfach schnell wieder hin.
Fahren jetzt einfach schnell wieder hin, easy.
Boating-New-Map.
Aber wir verlieren auch noch, ey, wir waren richtig gut die Runde.
Kommst du später noch Mauna, ich glaube schon.
Oh, oh.
Monarch.
Der Panzmann.
Ich würde gerne Web-Mounten, Moment.
Ich will, ich will, gib mir Sand-Crossing.
Was?
Ah, Gott ey, das ist ja der Wahnsinn, was hier abgeht.
Ich meine, an uns hat es jetzt nun wirklich die Runde nett gelesen, ne?
Ich glaube schon, dass ich später noch mal ankomme.
Und wir sind hier gelandet.
Ey, Alter.
Kratz mal ab.
Wo geht es dann 230 hin?
Äh, Abendessen.
Ansonsten nichts.
Es geht auch nirgendswo hin, weil heute ist ja, kann man nirgendswo hin.
Was irgendwie, wo man hingehen kann.
Die Soldatensprüche, Leute, ohne Scheiß.
Es gibt, also ich finde die COD 4 und MW2 Sprüche auch richtig geil, aber Battlefield 3 ist das Beste.
Wenn sie, was weiß ich hier, wenn sie rumschreien so, I get fucked in the ass over hier.
Oder was haben sie auch, I get drilled in your asshole.
Und solche, die Sprüche in Battlefield 3 sind einfach das Geilste.
Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr was ich an Overwatch, die besten, also die besten In-Game-Sounds in Overwatch,
war, also wo man gesehen hat, dass Blizzard sich richtig Mühe gegeben hat,
dass die Leute, je nachdem wo sie auf der Map runterfallen, unterschiedlich lange Schreisounds hatten.
Ich glaub das ist egal, was man votet.
Ich juck kein, was man votet, ist egal.
Den Kack votet doch keiner, wer votet denn sowas?
Übelste PP-Gas höchstens.
Wo ist der Mr. Army?
Das hat einfach mal das komplette gegnerische Team gekickt.
Das hat einfach das komplette Gegnerteam gekickt.
Mr. Army ist wieder da, nice.
Ähm, ich komm mal zu dir in Squad.
Weiß nicht genau wo hier, äh, tja.
Thief Squad.
Create Squad.
Ich mach mal ein neues Squad, ich bin jetzt in Kilo.
Äh, und du?
What is, what is happening?
Okay, nice.
Squad.
Wie ist er hier irgendwo?
Wo ist er?
Mr. Army, ich find dich grad net, aber, ähm.
Ach, der ist schon drinne, alles klar.
Exquisite.
Oh, sind wir zu spät gespawnt?
Das ist alles weg.
Bleibt stehen.
Kacknoobs, warte doch.
Was ist das?
Moment, Moment.
Das Balance Ding ist doch irgendwie ganz schön abgefuckt gerade.
Was passiert 2030?
Da muss ich essen.
Das heißt bis spätestens 2030.
Ich, wisst ihr was?
Die Vermutung hab ich auch.
Der Heli Typ, dem gehört der Server.
Und der wollte jetzt einfach ein Heli versus 64 Spieler,
dass er genug Kills machen kann.
Aber danach komm ich wahrscheinlich noch mal an.
Ähm, kann man auf die Sound-Dateien vom Spiel zugreifen?
Ja, ziemlich sicher geht das.
Ich hab mich aber noch nicht schlau gemacht, wie?
Aber ziemlich sicher geht das.
Grad mit Venice Unleashed geht das auf jeden Fall irgendwie.
What?
Ey, hat mich das jetzt rüberbalanced?
Ey, wollen die echt, dass ich, die wollen echt, dass ich disconnecte?
Wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen oder was?
Ich komm gleich wieder rein.
Ich geh jetzt raus und schäum wieder rein.
Was large.
Ey, ich mein, fast schon ein Akt bis, bis das jetzt gestartet ist
und jetzt haben sie mich einfach rübergeswitcht.
Bin ich wieder US.
Geil, was mach ich denn jetzt?
Ich will eigentlich zu meinem Team-Mate wieder rüber.
Gucken wir mal, warten wir mal ab.
Ich connecte mich einfach noch zweimal.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Metro?
On-Map Conquest?
Ach, ist das Conquest, der bis ins Freie geht?
Ich guck jetzt mal, wenn ich jetzt auf die russische Seite komme,
dann probier ich das noch mal.
Komm, please, Russland, komm, komm, fuck.
Tja, was willst du machen?
Du bist jetzt vom Sir, wenn du jetzt drauf gehst,
vielleicht kommst du jetzt auch ins US-Team.
Richtig tolles Auto-Balancing, ja.
Mega Poggers gebalanced.
Monarch.
Oh nee, das ist die Map mit AC-130.
Ich hab jetzt schon keinen Bock mehr.
Du bist jetzt vom Sir, kannst du gucken, ob du US kommst?
Wenn du nicht US kommst, geh mal auf einen anderen Server.
Ich kann nicht Team wechseln, geht nicht.
Team wechsel ist off.
Nee, nee.
Das wird also ein richtig pepega Ding.
Letzte Runde richtig gut, und jetzt?
Bist du der Army, wollen wir mal auf diesen Metro-Server?
Bist du wieder, bist du RU?
Wo ist AC?
Weg.
Das ist halt dumm, wenn du kein...
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, wenn du kein Team switchen kannst,
dann brauchst du eine Freundesliste,
wo du mit den Leuten zusammenspielen kannst,
weil sonst wird das ja im Leben nix.
Was du lässtst.
Oh nee.
Da musst du mir die jetzt alleine geben hier.
Beschreckt.
By the way, warum hab ich kein Panzer-Load-out?
Weißt du das? Nee, oder?
Pass mal auf, skillshot.
Hey, der klappen könnte.
Der Server ist...
Wollen wir mal auf diesen Metro-Server?
Metro-Conquest-Whole-Map.
Mein Problem ist, ich hab keinen Fernrohr dran.
What the f...
Okay, nee, nee, so funktioniert das mit diesen Dingern nicht.
Ja, so ein Zielfernrohr wäre schon nice, ne?
Au, what the hell?
Ah, was wird mit meinem Rohr?
Hinter mir ist was.
Hinter mir ist eine Artillerie.
Die, die PP-Gard rum.
What the f...
Hallo, schießen Panzer? Null.
Amörser auch noch.
Nee, komm, wir gehen jetzt auf diesen Metro-Server.
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr, der Server ist echt pains-champ.
Okay, wir kommen jetzt auf den Metro-Server.
Mal gucken, ob der was taugt.
Wenn der nichts taugt, dann geh ich auf den offiziellen Server
und baller mir noch ne Stunde Grand Bazaar Spawn-Rape rein.
Du hast durch beide Fenster geschossen, ja.
Ja, das ist wirklich die Metro in Pool.
Das ist Metro im Garten-Conquest.
Neu.
Wobei das Problem ist, die Map ist viel zu groß dafür.
Ich mein, guck mal, das ist ja riesig.
Egal, wir gehen jetzt rein.
Und dann gehen wir in den Tunnel und bashen einfach...
Alter, die Tickets!
What the fuck?
Sag mal, gibt's irgendeinen gescheiten Server noch?
Ist das irgendwas Normales?
Oh.
Meine Laune und Bock auf das Game schwinden gerade.
Nice.
Das ist PP-Gas hier, echt.
5 Trillionen Gegner vor allem.
Wieder mal für Commodore.
Moment, ich versuch mal zu disconnecten.
Vielleicht schaffen wir es.
O-M-G, Max, ja, ich...
O-M-G, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ach, Moment, wir sind ja gar kein Rush.
Lul.
Das war der Runde Rush-Spiel.
Einfach ne random Headshot.
Er ist nix getroffen an random Headshot.
Hast du als Programmierer eigentlich ne fancy custom Tastatur?
Nee.
Ganz normale mechanische Tastatur am Start.
Is this one-shot Headshot?
Ey, wenn, dann gibt's jetzt Rage Quit.
One-shot Headshot ist richtig dumm.
Also One-shot Headshot ist richtig PP-Gas-Kram.
Ja, der Map-Editor ist angeblich tatsächlich äußerst unstable.
Das hab ich auch schon gehört.
Zumal es wohl im Map-Editor so sein muss...
Hangman, ich weiß ja nicht, ob du da schon was gemacht hast.
Ich hab nur was drüber gelesen.
Dass du im Map-Editor keine neue Map machen kannst.
Sondern dass du im Map-Editor nur alte Maps verändern kannst.
Und auch nur mit den Sachen, die schon auf der Map drauf sind.
Was dazu führt, dass du beispielsweise keine komplett neue Rush-Map mit Sachen kombinieren kannst,
die es halt normalerweise so nicht gibt.
Ich trau mich hier nicht raus, Leute.
Easy, Yolo, Yolo!
Achtung!
Erstmal grob in die Richtung gesprayt.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was hier abgeht.
Aber...
Wisst ihr, ich sag euch, immer G18 rausnehmen.
Oh, nee.
Da war noch was.
Monka.
Wie heißt der Server? Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Metro.
Der einzige Server mit Metro, der Spieler hat gerade.
Metro-Whole-Map-Pepega-Stelz.
Die Stelzen da unten drin, kann das sein?
Wo sind die Pepegas?
Ist nix?
Wow!
0W.
Cool, okay.
Kommt gleich was von unten?
Ja, schießt hier mal weiter rein.
Alles okay.
Ist gut, ist gut.
Macht weiter.
Ich hab, ich hab Zeit.
Ich hab Zeit.
Ich hab Zeit, Leute.
Hat da von oben gerade einer runtergeschossen?
Ah, nee.
Wollte man hier durchschießen?
Ja, oh, nice.
Gegner, wo seid ihr?
Wo seid ihr?
Dein Pepegas.
Da kommt gleich einer hoch.
Null.
Direkt.
Wie sie reinrennen.
Okay, 18 Euro.
Okay, das war doof.
Das war den zu Yolo retzen.
Oh mein Gott, wie sind die noch da?
Moment.
Oh, da sitzt unten drin der Dude.
Fuck.
Okay, das wird...
Da kommt gleich was.
Ich brauch nicht.
Okay, jetzt darf er mal wieder.
Alles klar, Battlefield, gut.
Easy.
Der hat halt schon gewartet.
Kann man die Dinger nicht kaputt machen?
Ist das irgendwas Neues?
Das ist irgendwie...
Das ist irgendwie ein neuer Champ, dass man die Dinger nicht kaputt machen kann.
Ich muss hier weg Leute, ich muss hier weg.
Ich krieg Anfälle, wenn ich hier weiter drin bleiben muss.
Achtung.
Oh fuck.
Okay, die schätze ich noch.
Und jetzt.
Evaded.
Nein.
Massive Play Potential.
Okay, ich glaub wir haben es verschissen.
Also ich finde Teamswitchen verboten ist dumm.
Wenn du kein Freundessystem hast, musst du Teamswitchen können.
Warum hat der Server eigentlich 50 Billionen Tickets?
Da ist der Captain Peng, ich hab ihn genau gesehen.
Der Captain Peng war da.
Der Typ ist noch da.
Der Dude ist noch da.
Und nur drei Flanken.
Also wir hätten auf jeden Fall mehr Flanken positionieren müssen, ja.
Auf jeden Fall.
Fühl ich Digger.
Ah.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Der weiß, dass ich da bin.
Wie?
Nicht tot?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich hab dem halbes Magazin reingedrückt da hinten dem Dude.
Aber ne, ne, ne, nicht sterben.
Weil wir haben B grade verloren?
Da rennen wir jetzt ja drei Stunden, Alter.
Pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt Squad Change Abuse.
Jawoll, jetzt sind wir nämlich wieder.
Ha.
You got evaded.
G-G-G-G-G-Baited
G-G-G-G-Baited
Die kriegen auf den Sack
G-G-Baited
Die haben wir gerade gebashed, hä?
Massive Bash haben wir gemacht
Huge Bash
Poggers Bash
Da war er
Hopp
Nein, nein
Multiple things
Fixed tonight
Silvester Update
Das wär natürlich Poggers
Interessant wie Metro
nicht in den Campfest ausartet
Noch nicht
Fucking Grenade
Oh
Warum hab ich das überlebt, ey?
Da is er
Da ist der Army
Oh fuck
Achtung, der Dude kommt jetzt raus
Ich hab Schiss
Oh ne, oh ne, oh ne
Lass mich landen
XX Helen
XX
Ob das RL Grill ist?
Ein RL
Battlefield Grill
Chat, was mein ihr?
Bestimmt, oder?
Das ist ja bekanntermaßen so hier
Nebar RuneScape
Das Online Spiel
mit den meisten
RL Grills
Oh, ich trau mich nicht dahin
Ich sag das Campfest ist schon wieder
Oh fuck, okay wir müssen da jetzt mal raus
Hier mein wir killen immerhin auch was, ne?
Okay, jetzt sind wir so pressed
Jetzt machen wir erstmal nix mehr
wenn wir so pressed sind
Suppression, darf ich da bitte mal reinschießen?
Ist das möglich?
Ich mach einfach Hitmarker
Ich kann vor lauter Suppression ja eh nix machen
Lul, alter
So kennt man es in Metro
Oh mein Kopf
Das ist der hübsche Rotz, Lul
Ja schon irgendwo
Wir können danach noch ne Runde
Official spielen
Nice Metro Camp Action
Excellent, excellent, excellent
Wie komm ich denn hier jetzt raus?
Smoke, Smoke ist Poggers
Ammo, Ammo haben wir hier
Da ist Ammo, Ammo, Ammo
Pass mal auf, ich mach jetzt
den YOLO Mode aller Zeiten
Mach ich jetzt gleich, fuck
Was?
Nein
Ah
Metro Beste
Metro ist Resident Sleeper hoch 10
Es gibt nen, es gibt nen kein Suppression Mod
Gibt es, gibt es
Pass mal auf
Pass mal auf Leute
Hat nicht funktioniert
Ah, Kokomodots im Chat sind
Oh, oh, oh, da stellts der
Da stellts der
Ein nicer Stellzer
Das zackt, alter
Richtig dumm
Das ist richtig Pepega
Richtig Pepega Shit
Richtig Pepega Kram
Ok, also
Das ist die letzte, das ist der letzte Surfer
den wir noch nicht ausprobiert haben
Alle anderen haben wir mehr oder weniger durch
Das ist halt Metro, ne?
Das ist halt Metro
Richtig dumm
Ich seh nix
Was?
Richtig dumm
Smoke
Monka, Smoke
Das tut weh, alter
Wir machen jetzt Leute
Bis 20.30 Uhr
Nein, wir machen keine Metro bis 20.30 Uhr
Ich geb mir das jetzt noch mal gucken
Wie lang geht denn die Runde noch?
Lol, alter
Das ist doch Pepega Alter noch 1800 Tickets
1800 Tickets, really?
Oh ne, oder?
Richtig dumm
Alter, das ist so krass Pepega Shit
Auf der anderen Seite kommen gerade die Gegner runter
Das ist wirklich nur für Braindead
Das ist echt nur für Braindead
Also wer das länger als 20 Minuten spielen kann
Dann weiß ich auch nicht
Was? Du kannst mich überhaupt nicht sehen, Alter
Pass auf, die Bahn kommt
Das ist kein Problem, wir wissen ja prinzipiell, dass die Bahn nicht kommt
Das heißt da kann man sich auch auf die Metro legen
Wie? Kein Kill?
Wie, das waren alle?
Guck mal, Suppression Assist, Suppression Assist
Das ist wirklich nur eine Stelle ab
Im Prinzip
Geht's hier eigentlich weiter?
Nee, oder? Hier ist doch jetzt gleich Schloss
Nee
Das kann ich nicht lange spielen, Leute
Also wir spielen noch
Wir machen noch bis 17.700 Tickets
Dann ist vorbei
Da kommt gleich was rein
600 Tickets noch
Im Leben spielen wir keine 600 Tickets
Das kann ich euch gleich sagen
600 Tickets spielen wir im Leben nicht
Oh
Nee
Sorry, Leute
Tut mir leid, ich halte es dann aus
Das ist zu brain dead
Das ist wirklich zu brain dead
Aber
Ich save mir das mal, nämlich aus dem
Einfachen Grund
Man kann da super Sachen
Rausschneiden aus Metro, shit
Also
Das hatten wir gerade
Nee, das war das andere
Rausschneiden
Ach nee, das ist der 64-Spieler
Raussch
Der hat auch gesackt
One Bullet Headshots
Das ist auch sackt
Okay, es gibt keinen Server, den wir ausprobieren können
Wir müssen
Official Server spielen
Nehmen wir mal den hier
Easy
Was hat der für eine Rotation
TDM
Was ist das für eine beknackte Rotation
Demo wenn Peek Rush
Map Rotation
TDM Nosha Candles
What the fuck
Ist keiner mehr in der Lage
Irgendwelche normalen Server zu machen
Wir machen den Server voll
Ja, wenn wir genug Leute haben
Machen wir den Server voll
Guck nochmal schnell
Ob es hier noch was Gescheites gibt
Ja, dann machen wir doch den Server voll
Was sehen wir denn
Was machen wir, einfach
Easy Server füllen
Okay
Ja
Was ist das Problem
Wenn ich so ein Listo
Fuck Source
Scheiße, was weiß ich denn
Mein Passwort, das weiß ich doch aus dem Kopf nicht mehr
Okay
Jetzt habe ich ein Problem
Okay, wartet mal, wartet mal, ich glaube ich weiß es
Ha
Massive
Ja, das hat sich abgemeldet
Passwort QChat
123, korrekt
Rush at night, 250 Tickets
Das klingt gut Captain Peng
Das suchen wir erstmal, Filter
Rush, ne
Rush
Nein
Night
Auf dem haben wir noch letztens gespielt
Der war noch gar nicht übel
Rush at night
Rush at night, 200
Ne, nicht nochmal Metro
Ne, ne
Wir nehmen den hier, auf dem waren wir doch letztens auch schon
Alliance Apps
IO Official 01
Rush 24, Steam Rush Epicenter
Auf gehts
QChat
Such mal Randomizer Mod
Shotgun mit 20 Zoom
Das ist eher was
Das ist eher was für Gun Game
Oder
Ne, 99er Peng stimmt nicht, da haben wir im Endeffekt
Ein 10er Peng
Was hält der Informatiker von Bitcoins
Ich hab von so Stonks Kram keinen Plan
Epicenter Rush, ne
Captain Poggers ist da, jawoll
Ich hab schon
Ehm
Glaub
WTF was wollte ich
Das ist scheiße wenn ich 5 Sachen gleichzeitig gucke
Das wollte ich grad sagen
Ja also ich hab von Bitcoin Kram keine Ahnung
Und dann hab ich vergessen was ich sagen wollte
Weil ich grad auf dem zweiten Monitor geguckt hab
Und was nachgeguckt hab
Poggers Refrag
Komm wir machen jetzt voll
Hast kein DLC
Du brauchst keine DLC
Du brauchst nur die DLC Dateien irgendwo her
Ich weiß G-Bate
Captain Poggers hat mich gehauen
Was ist das?
Stellt der da oben in der Ecke der Typ?
Da ist er
Was ist das der da oben?
Die Nate?
Die haben Massive Nate geschmissen
By the way
Die Runde geht noch gar nicht los
In der Pre-Dings
In der Hoffnung dass wir das voll kriegen
Ist der Stream eigentlich hell genug
Mit Nachtmaps
Also bei mir ist es ok
Aber ich weiß ja nicht wie es
Komprimiert im Stream aussieht
Ja Twitch Zuschauer
Das wünschen wir dir auch
Ist ok
Die G18 ist so ein OP Ding
Kann ich mal 2 Meter laufen
Please
Der denn?
Im Anfall
Wir haben Doppelsprint
Jetzt geht das wieder los
Ok also was haben wir gelernt
Ich joine gleich wieder Leute
Was haben wir gelernt wir müssen Appdata
Appdata
Local
Wenn es unleashed und Mods löschen
Dann haben wir Glück
Mach halt Origin zu
Was hat das damit
Ernsthaft was zu tun?
Wisst ihr was
Das ist potentiell echt ein Problem
Wenn die Mods runterladen
Im Hintergrund
Wenn irgendeiner
Ein Lua Bitcoin Miner programmiert
Dann minen alle Bitcoins
Für den
Oh das haben die mich gerade auf die Idee gebracht
Vielleicht sollte ich auch ein
Leash Mod machen
Um mein Krypto Portfolio aufzustocken
Ja super ist kein Platz mehr im Squad
BF3 ohne Battle.net
Exquisite Battle.net
Wo geht es eigentlich hier hin und lang
127 Metru Bitcoin Miner
Man muss das nur so machen
Dass man es nicht merkt
Ja ne das ist Origin in dem Fall
Squad please
Empty Slot
Von wegen Empty Slot
Das ist echt ein Problem
Das ist ein Problem
Von wegen Empty Slot
Von wegen
Kann man hier irgendeine Flank Action machen
Ich weiß nicht ob wir den Server voll kriegen Leute
War Epicenter nicht die Map
Wo man
Löcher überall rein sprengen konnte
Ich wette mit euch Streamsnipe
Ich sag's euch
Ich sag euch Streamsnipe
Massive Nate Max
Beste Nate aller Zeiten
Was wie M.Com destroyed
Lul
War das geiler defused
Keck
Ok Leute also
Wer noch Bock hat kann join
Weil wir müssen den Server voll kriegen
Der zweite Spann von mir ist in einem Haus
Da muss es zu sein
Das überfordert die Battlefield Sprung Mechanik
Die ist schreishause
Wir könnten ja wieder Infrarot Visier spielen
Was
Das nix gestorben
What the fuck
Ich hab extra schon auf den zweiten geswitcht gerade
Weil ich dachte der erste ist jetzt down
Keck
Omega keck
Ich hol dich
Oder auch nicht
Der ist bestimmt noch innen tot
Da ist garantiert noch einer Leute
Was
Oh no
Der sneaky
Aber so macht man's Leute
So speak brain plays
Angesagt
Bis der Ami macht das gerade in meinem Eingang
Lasst mich raus
Wir müssen das ganze nämlich schön abcampen hier
Massive abcamp
Komm die können die von hier hinten stelzen
Fuck man ich wusste es dass sie diffusen
Wie der Server heißt
Such nach Epicenter Map
Oder irgendwas mit Alliance
Alliance Official 01 oder so
Nice
Ich find's ja nice Team
Dass ihr mir die Punkte gönnt
Gönne Reno
Weggeknallt alle in den Kopf
Wie das wars schon
Moment Moment Moment
Epicenter ist dann vorbei
Geht es nicht noch weiter
Erzhaft hat Epicenter
Nur die 3 M
Komms da
Jetzt wird das aber langsam voll
Bis denn wie wusste
Exzellent
Ich scroll mal kurz über den Chat drüber
Ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab
Weil bestimmt
Leute kennen ihr das
Wenn ihr jetzt Urlaub hattet
Ich hab jetzt am 18. November Urlaub
Absolut kein Bock wieder arbeiten zu gehen
Immer so
Der erste erste ein zwei Tage
Sind übelst ätzend
Wo sollen wir überhaupt hin
Monster of Jelly
Ich bin ein wenig planlos
Wo genau kommen Gehschnos her
Und sich durchballern oder
Ja klar
Dumm gepiekt
Extrem größer Arbeit
Ja ich hab's ja schon gesagt
Ich bin am überlegen ob ich auf 3 Tage verkürze das Ganze
Der Captain Poggers
Alter was soll ich noch machen
Mehr auf Kopfhöhe zielen kann ich ja nicht
Oh da kommen sie raus gestürmt
Und nein
Da unten
Ich höre links von mir noch was laufen
Nein nein nein
Pass auf
Gerade Nate geworfen
Jetzt kommt von oben was
Fuck
Ich weiß nicht wo ich hin soll
Nice
Was sind das für Spons
What Monka
Wir sind Defender wir müssten eigentlich da hinten stehen
Sollen wir nicht
Such einfach nach Night Mode
Night
Und dann Rush
Night und Rush
Da gibt's in Kombination nicht so viel
Oh Mist
Fuck
Alter ich kann ja mehr zielen
Voll dreimal vorbei
Genau
So einfach Night Time und Rush
So einfach wo Leute drauf sind
Nur unserer
Mehr gibt's nicht
Pass auf von oben kommen da 30 Millionen Gegner klar
Auch von hinten stellt es da was
Wow wow wow
Ist gut ist gut ist gut ist gut ist gut
Alter lass mich in Ruhe
Die bescheuertste
Weg ever
Wenigstens ordentliche Ticket
Anzahl hier
Viele sind da nicht mal
Kommen sie von oben
Alter
Wie hat er denn jetzt gerätzt und gleichzeitig
Geballert
Ich finde die normale Serverliste besser
Ja die normale Serverliste
Offizielle die kaum Bugs hatten gut funktionieren
Aber ich muss sagen die haben auch schon
Ein paar Probleme wie gesagt keine Server Queue suckt mal
Richtig
Massive suck ehrlich gesagt
Irgendwo da unten stellt es doch
Noch was oder
Hier
Ah
Da merkste gleich
Gescheite Gegner
Also
Ich muss sagen ich finde
Mit 24
Mit 24 Spielern
Ist es ok mit 100%
Kann man schon ein bisschen mehr geben
Was
Fuck die haben gelegt
Die lege Henne ist real Leute
Lege Henne
Ah
BG Eats
Was der P steckt fest ok
But why
Habt ihr gerade gesehen das ganze Haus hat geleuchtet
Ja
Ich
Kleist
Moment
Leute hier kein Spawn
Das suckt
Da liefen die Gegner höchstens
Na gut macht eh keiner
Ja
Kein Bock auf
Laberstellz
Wisst ihr worauf ich ja Bock
Hätte
Bezüglich Laberstellz
Oh da kommt ein Auto
What the hell
Gut gedacht Leute
Definitiv sehr gut gedacht
Poggers Poggers
Attacker
Sehr gut sehr gut gemacht
Also das ist Big Brain Attack gewesen
Ich meine das ernst
Und ich wusste gar nicht das man hier oben
Auto oh fuck
Ist der von da gerade aus hier oben drüber gefahren
Oder was hat er getrieben
Ja Leute mal zurück damit gelegt
Gelege Henne
Ah ne doch nicht
Oh wir haben hier Auto das ist jetzt nicht so fein
Da steht er
War wall bang die nade
Schlecht gezielt
Was
Erstmal Leute retten
Ich rette lieber Leute bevor ich die
Oh nice
Der ist voll im Kopf reingelaufen habt ihr es gesehen
Lull
Auch von hinten kommt wieder ein Auto
Pass mal auf
Massive flank kommt jetzt
Huge flank
Moment meine Leute rennen da schon rum
Wie soll ich da flank machen wenn ihr schon da seid
Das ist ja unfair
Oh jetzt haben sie es
Jetzt haben sie es gut
Der normale Server Browser
Der Captain Poggers
Der normale Server Browser ist ganz okay
Der tut
Schreckt
Nice Attack
GG Eats
Da hinten ist noch einer
Alter
Du mein mit der Spass
Spass Lachs oder was hier los
Schlagerino
Schauen wir noch
Oh nice smoke
Nein
Silvester Stream
Ja bis 20.30
20.30 gibt es Essen
Da muss kurz
Und danach komme ich wieder
An Start
Jetzt wollte es aber wissen hier die
Wow
Oh
Pass mal auf
Massive flank
Flank des Jahrhunderts
Only big brain plays ab jetzt
Da ist doch
Only big brain plays
Da oben sind die
Da oben
Ich dachte die kommen von da unten hochgelaufen
Nee das Essen wird nicht so spektakulär
Leute
Ich bestell eine Runde Burger
Das war ohne Scheiß
Wir machen heute gar nichts
Ich juckte es am Ohr
Wo ist der Captain Poggers
Poggers hat sich ausgebrochen
Ich habe mich verletzt
Poggers hat sich ausgepoggert
Ich wusste es doch
Dass du einer stellst
Crispy Chicken Burger
So muss es sein Sebaro
Jetzt muss man sagen
Jetzt artet schon ein bisschen Gegner Spawn Rave aus
Oh komm
Das ist das Levolution Event
Ich glaube das war das Levolution Event
Für die Map und ich habe keine Ahnung was das eigentlich macht
Jetzt können wir nächste Runde spielen
Ich mein
Spawn Bash brauchen wir die Gegner ja echt nicht
Da legt doch bestimmt gerade einer
Achtung
Wir gewinnen das E
Kirby
Gourmet Race
Exzellent
Jetzt wollen sie es wissen hier
Das ist übelst unfair gerade
Da hätte ich keinen Bock mehr
Also wenn ich Gegner wäre würde ich jetzt keinen Bock mehr
Dann würde ich Instant Rage Quit
Deswegen mache ich jetzt auch nichts mehr
Dann würden sie noch
Früher war das nice
Soll ich euch noch was sagen was mir aufgefallen ist
Bei Montages
Bei Youtube Montages
Zu Trick Shot Zeiten
War ja total im Trend
Dass man dann gemacht hat
So ihr wisst was ich meine
Also Massive Dubstep
Und es hat am Anfang immer angefangen
Dann hat er seine geilen Trick Shots gemacht
Und heute ist das so
Du könntest ja Magnum snipen
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee
Heute ist das so
Heute ist das irgendwie ein komischer
Autotune Billigrap
In den Montages drin
Sollte euch das auch mal aufgefallen
Früher war das
Richtig nerviges
Over the top Dubstep
Und
Ernsthaft
Richtig Over the top Dubstep
Und jetzt ist das so Billig
Autotune Rap
In den ganzen Montages
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was ich schlechter finde
Die haben es aber hart durchgezogen
Die Jungs hier noch
Ich hab schon quasi nur noch Channels
Die haben es aber hart durchgezogen
Die Jungs hier noch
Ich hab schon quasi nur noch Chat gelesen
Nach der Hälfte der Runde
Weil es ein wenig unbalanced war
Die haben auch durchgezogen hier
Was jetzt kommt
Also wie gesagt ich bin nicht sehr
Ich fand den Dubstep jetzt nicht so geil
Aber das ging noch irgendwie
Aber so Autotune Rap
Verfolgt irgendjemand
Diese Faze
Wie heißt das Faze 5
Faze S
Diese Leute joinen Faze
Competition
Das hab ich ja ewig
Nicht mehr gespielt
Operation Riverside Rush
Das ist ohne Scheiß
Das ist 5-6 Jahre her
Als ich das gespielt hab
Falls irgendjemand diese
Sache verfolgt
Mit
Ja Chat
Guckt keiner mehr von euch
Ich glaub da läuft man nicht
Das ist ein bisschen weit
Ok Massive
Das ist richtig weit weg
Guck mal wo das ist
Hauptsache erstmal
Random reingesprayt
Was ich euch fragen wollte Leute
Hat irgendjemand von euch mitgekriegt
Wenn der letzte
Joiner war
Oh fuck
Es gab hier noch diesen komischen
Scope Typ der joinen wollte
Der irgendwelche
Montages da hochgeladen hat
Weil ich hab's überhaupt
Nicht mehr verfolgt
Mich interessiert einfach nur wer gewonnen hat
Massive easy
Das ist Bad Company 2 Remake
Hat aber was von
Hat voll was von Bad Company 2
Die Map
Und gerade bei Nacht Finish die mega nice
Heli Stelzer
Wow
Ja
Da droppt der Beat
DLC Map
Ja der Server scheint erstmal jetzt alle
DLC Maps durch zu rotaten
Bevor der Rest kommt
Move up
Wie lang das hier ist
Dass ich die Map gespielt hab
Bei Nacht scheint die Sonne
Ist der Mond
Na klar die Himmel Textur ist halt nur mal die Sonne
Achtung Stelz Attack
Stelz Attack
1-2 Stelz Attack
Massive Anschleich Stelz machen wir jetzt
Guckt euch mal an
Huge
Wie wir hier an Stelz das kann keiner
Wir sind komplett unsichtbar
Da war hier nicht eben einer
Was zum Teufel
Warum sterben die alle nicht
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln
Ich rollen
Hier vielleicht kann ich dich retzen
Hier ist auch einer
Der Server hat kein Auto Balancing
Das heißt die Teams bleiben
Immer so wie sie sind
Aber ey Leute können wir mal please gescheites Server haben
Ich mein das ist doch unfair
Ja Leute guck mal die liefen schon
Was
Was was war man da jetzt
Ich geh jetzt
Ich change jetzt Team easy
Ach ne geht ja nicht
Ja das sackt
Ist richtig dumm
Was sind das für Gegner
Es sehen alle Gegner pepega aus wenn das Team insgesamt schlechter ist
Hallo
Ja
Kein Bock
Suche Squad für Silvester und später
Naja ich bin wahrscheinlich nahe nicht da
Das ist dumm
Was muss man rechtsklick
Assist
Ah
Aha
Poggers
Ach so geht das
So welche
Aha aha
Jetzt
Macht es ja Sinn
Komm was Bashing alter
Bashing machen wir jetzt
Bashing alter Bashing kommst du her
Jawoll
Jetzt haben wir wenigstens was zum killen
Easy
Wisst ihr jetzt geht das auch
Wonka
Wie viele Leute
Aber jetzt weiß ich wenigstens wie man
Switcht
Nice
So ist es nice
Da kann man wenigstens selbst ein bisschen
Balancen
Wie soll man das wissen
Only only big brain
So filtert man halt einfach die
Leute mit low brain raus
Entweder man weiß es oder man weiß es nicht
Der LLV steht da ein bisschen ungünstig
Der LLV steht da wirklich sehr ungünstig
Da komm ich nicht durch
Ach da brauchen wir auch einen extra Mod für
Ok ok verstehe verstehe
So
Wonka es
Och nee
Ausgerechnet jetzt wo ich den grad schön drauf
geaimt hab
Nice
Hallo
Wonka
Also jetzt ist grad big brain warfare hier
angesagt
Richtig big brain warfare
Komm mal hier wie es sich da versucht wird outzuplayen
Kommst ja schon vor wie ein CS
By the way ich bin mir grad sicher wo hier
Wo ist hier grad auf mich sniped
Wo snipes denn hier überhaupt auf mich
Big brain warfare
Oh haben wir das schon verloren
Oh wir haben schon alles verloren lul
Tactical header
Leute ich glaube wir
sind weg Leute
Wir müssen weg
Die können schon seit 3 Stunden planten da hinten
Und wir stellsten mit dem alten
Team hier an der Lagerhalle rum
Tactical header
Auf gehts
Was hat der gemacht
Was war mit dem los
Ok
Guck mal wir stellsten mit dem halben Team hier rum
Und die Gegner machen einfach mal den
Banana plant
Jetzt aber
Jetzt, jetzt, guck mal, guck mal
Wir haben jetzt hier schön aufgeräumt
Und da drüben
Da drüben
Schön aufgeräumt
Und da drüben geht gerade die Runde verloren
Richtig
Richtig schlecht
What the fuck
Oh da kommt noch was
Ok Kirby muss aus
Ich hab den nicht gehört
Aber ohne Scheiß
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser balanced
Wenn man sich das ganze wenigstens halbwegs geben
Sag mal Mr.Ami bist du afk
So nach dem Motto
Einfach jetzt easy loss
Weil normalerweise bist du ja
Immer mit kills so ganz eng vor mir
Schon gedacht
Ah
Ah ah ah ah
Pains Jam
Wow
Der Klatsch
Der Klatsch Keppo ist am Start
Scheiße
Hab mich gedartet
Across the map
Excellent
Fuck ich wusste es, ich wusste es Leute
Das ist fies, das ist fies das Ding
Das ist echt fies
Ich versuche es mal
Der Typ da sitzt oben drauf
Komm, vielleicht kriegen wir es
Ich supresse einfach mal
Ok das halbe Team sitzt schon dran
Alles klar, alles klar
Easy
What is happening
Hier ist jetzt so viel los auf einmal
Hier nichts mehr zu sehen
Blankchamp, flankchamp
Ok
Rättschamp
Hallo
Die kommen jetzt von der anderen Seite
Ich wette mit euch
Die Gegner sind nicht doof
Die kommen jetzt von der anderen Seite gestellt
Ich sag es euch
Wow
Pepega aimed
Oh nee an A
Übrigens ich hab das Gefühl
Das ist übelst unfair für die Defender hier
Äh für die Attacker
Weil die den Berg hoch müssen
Und irgendwie kriegen die alle voll auf den Sack
Wenn die den Berg hoch gehen
Ich kann mich dran erinnern
Ich hatte mal auf der Xbox
Als ich auf der Xbox gespielt hab
Hatte ich mal eine brutal krasse Runde
Auf der Map
Da hab ich hier vorne bei dieser Power Plant Station
Wie auch immer
Mit der Silenced AEK
Gekämpft im Gegnersporn
Die haben ich net gesehen
Ich erinnere mich
Massive Poggers Runde
War das
Ok
Ich hab kein Rätsel
Moin
Oh fuck
Jetzt hab ich Chat gekockt
Yep
Sebaro ist bei dir Feuerwerk am Start?
Bei mir ist nichts
Absolut gar nichts diesmal
Null, auch die Tage vorher
Gar nichts
Bleib uns 2021
Also ich hab nicht vor irgendwie
Corona mäßig den Löffel abzugeben
Oder so
Ist nicht geplant
Oh, oh jetzt wird gepusht
Ich seh nix
Oh jetzt haben sie es Leute
Jetzt haben sie es
Die kleinen PP Gas
Ok, jetzt haben sie es
Die haben es auch noch geschafft
Alter
Dass du noch am Start bist
Ich bin ja wieder am Start
Ich hab jetzt 6 Jahre in Ankommerz gemacht
Die Flares schauen ein oder so aus
Sebaro wohnt in Offenbach
Tja, möglich
In Offenbach gehts halt bestimmt gut
Offenbach ist ja so ein Ding
Im Zweifelsfall gehts da immer rund
Ey Nubi ist schon klar
Ich weiß schon was du meinst
Ich weiß was du meinst
Ich versuch weiter
Content zu produzieren
Echt? Ohne Scheiß Leute
Ich hab die letzten
Seit wann durfte man
Feuerwerk theoretisch verkaufen
Man darf nicht, aber
Man hätte dürfen, wenn es keine
Regelung gibt, seit Dienstag
Ich hab diese ganze Woche vielleicht einmal
Irgendwo was knallen gehört
Es ist nix
Jetzt auch nix, nix
Meine Katz freut es
Meine Katz findet das Pock
Unbewusst findet ihr das Pock
Die Katz wird eh wieder
Massive verwirrt
Weil heute hier bis mindestens 24 Uhr
Leute am Start sind
Katzen sind ja unglaublich scharf drauf
Das alles jeden Tag gleich
ist
Ups
Wenn nicht alles jeden Tag gleich ist
Sackt für die Katz
Oh sind die grad auf mich gesniped
Sind sie alle gelieft
Ok der Server hat
Fragwürdige
Spielerverteilung gerade
Ich glaub da sitzt gar keiner dran
Am Mörser
Strike
Also Leute wir haben heute keine
Großartige Glück irgendwie mit
Und nice Runden und so
Weil wir bashen ja
Das machen wir, Massive bash ist angesagt
Aber es ist entweder
Gebashed werden oder
Total Gegnerzerstörung
Was beides Kacke ist
Am liebsten hab ich
Die Runden wo man gut basht
Aber wo es richtig abgeht und schwer ist
Also bashen
Gegen gescheite Gegner
So mach ich das
Ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht
Ich mein es gibt immer mal wieder
Immer mal wieder Runden wo man sagt
Hey wäre ja nice
Wenn man mal bashen
Einfach mal durch bash
Als Entspannung, ansonsten könnte man
Ja auch gleich Skill-Based Matchmaking machen
What the fuck
By the way Leute ich sag's euch
Ich sag euch Battlefield 6 kommt raus
Und dann kommt raus Battlefield hat
Skill-Based Matchmaking
Und dann sagen
Dann sagen alle Kacke
Im Kopf
Komm mal es sind keine Gegner mehr da
Was ist das denn
Lull
Das ist doch Müll
Das ist doch echt
Ich switche nicht nochmal rüber
Ich hab letzte Runde rüber geswitcht
Ja ich will auch entspannt spielen
Aber manchmal will ich halt auch ein bisschen
Bisschen Bash-Modus anmachen
Gegen nicht ganz so braindead Gegner
Ne das ist so krass
Ne das ist dumm
Das ist richtig dumm
Pass mal auf wir sprengen uns jetzt easy in die
Luft
Komm mal her
Achso
Das Ding explodiert gar nicht
Ich hab es absichtlich schon vorbei
geschossen alter
Ohne Teamswitch ist richtig Müll
Ja genau
Rechts klicken und dann
Assist
Irgendjemand
Irgendjemand rüber schieben kann man nicht
Wie umständlich
Ja richtig umständlich
Oh
Bin ich so Pains Champ
Oh oh oh
Kommt was
Was fettes kommt da gefahren
Boah
Der Shotgun Champ
In die Fresse geschossen
Da liegt er mit
Dart
Pistol Dart Kombi
Exquisite
Nur die Besten der Besten
Au
Oh guck mal
Die Gegner machen ja was
Kommt der LLV
Angestellst
Leute wisst ihr was geil wäre
Wenn ich Warzone so geil finden würde wie Battlefield
Dann könnte ich voll
Warzone Click
Click Champ machen auf YouTube
Aber ich kann mich nicht zwingen dazu Sachen zu spielen
Das krieg ich halt gebacken
Ich muss das aus Überzeugung machen
Wenn ich das nicht aus
Wenn ich das nicht spiele weil ich es geil finde
Dann wäre ich nicht gut
Und ich hab kein Bock
Wobei man sagen muss Warzone ist okay
Aber jetzt so
Dieses Ultra Durchsucht Game
Ist es für mich einfach nicht
Der Realtalk am Start hier
Boah
Boa
mouth
warzone aus leute warzone ist anstrengend ja das stimmt gibt's hier schon hex na klar
das game hat keinen anti cheat kannst einfach eins zu eins alle battlefield 3 hex nehmen
easy win aber ich hoffe mal dass die meisten leute die hier spielen eh eh eh eh ehren ehrenmänner
sind ja warzone ist nur so erfolgreich wegen feel to play ja klar natürlich man hat ja
gesehen battlefield hat es ja probiert mit diesem komischen firestorm ding was auch zum
beispiel die plattenmechanik von modern warzone hatte und was auch ziemlich casual mäßig battle
royal war uns hat keinen interessiert aber kann es halt auch nicht bringen
ich bringe einfach mal wild rum in der offensichtlichkeit
das schießt gar nicht auf uns nur
heute ist langweilig sagt ich fange schon an übelst sinnloses zeug zu machen
da stellen sie in den kopf gestellst
by the way eine frage kennt ihr das dass ihr nach einer weile anfangen wenn ihr den spiel
wirklich lange durchgegrindet habt dass ihr anfangen zu so kreative plays zu machen zum
beispiel so was wie hier zu piken das liegt ich habe in meinem leben noch nie über diese
ecke gepiekt aber so in games die man eine weile gekreidet hat
da macht man so was automatisch
kommst du raus
jetzt aber endlich mal fuß fuß jem den hat es zerrissen haben die kein punkbuster wollen
sie in zukunft machen der normale punkbuster scheint nicht so zu funktionieren
vor allen den haben sie hier exekuted den typ
depends man is back schwer gerebt
ich habe übrigens keine keine ausrüstung für den pence man also wenn jemand anderes
will müssen wir hier weg kurz
und jetzt muss ich nachladen jetzt ernsthaft jetzt wo ich gefickt hätte
wie ach hier geht es lang keine ahnung ob es lange
ich weiß gar nicht von wo
das eben von der seite muss weg
noch mehr dpi auf der maus massive pence man am start hier
ja hinter mir das habe ich jetzt auch gar mitgekriegt was hat sich jetzt erledigt
hallo hallo tippe Hash on
Kommt mir gleich um die Ecke, ich sag's euch.
Ecken, Eckenstells.
Du, also die Runde ist echt easy champ.
Ja, ich mein' DPI an der Maus, mein' ich doch.
Residenz Leaper.
Mit ASDF, ja ich hab' nichts ausgequippt für den LLV.
Das war komplett, komplett Default.
Leute, was macht ihr denn heute Abend?
Weiß noch, so machen kann man ja nix.
Ähm, macht ihr irgendwas?
Ja Leute, ich geh' ja auch futtern jetzt.
Also nicht jetzt direkt, aber ich mach' jetzt auch Schluss.
Und dann geh' ich zwanzig oder dreißig essen.
Und nachher, nachher guck' ich mal.
Nachher guck' ich mal, ich glaub' ich, ich, ich glaub' ich komm' nachher nochmal on.
Aber Schluss für heute, reicht.
Bis dann Leute, wir sehen uns, CU.